please welcome Simon Helberg
[Applause]
[Applause]
so I love it when I don't sometimes I
get a chance to come back and say hi to
the guests before the show I did not get
a chance today and you're wearing this
fantastic
well leprechaun suit I look like Santa's
agent oh yeah Robin Williams right now
someone's on the North Pole going this
is fan also feel that end I know I
already did just rub in revving this is
why I wear it I need in a man sandwich
oh my god you're a meaty guy yeah we're
just gonna we're gonna do that to you
the whole segment now good thing is the
pants aren't high at all I know I
enjoyed both the rat on halyard I have
really long legs so when I pull my pants
up like that it's an absolute freak
[Applause]
that is that is though the most it's the
like whenever you see old men and old
movies working like pastor it is the
most comfortable way to wear your pants
it is just below the nipple right it's
also a bib yeah it's your waistband yeah
and you're eating chowder or whatever it
doesn't matter nothing binding down here
just sweet flowing fabric take a breath
just undo my fly it's so long I feel
like rest this is already the dumbest
interview I've conducted but I'm loving
it it's really fun I'm so happy I wore
this yeah it's fantastic stop fiddling
with yourself leave it alone you can't
help it yeah all right but you've been
thrown off the bus today
you